se ha dicho mucho de Quiénes son los
ganadores después de la invasión
norteamericana 2013 es que realmente lo
subo porque las pérdidas humanas y la
violencia que se ha creado en Irak es
inmensamente grande en estos últimos 20
años obviamente muchos hablan que los
ganadores fueron los kurdos que ganaron
estabilidad después de esa persecución
que tuvieron Durante los años de que los
fue atacando y asesinando en algunas
masacres muchas veces con ataques de
armas químicas en su momento pero
también los chiítas que fueron los que
retomaron el poder no solamente político
del país sino que pudieron volver a
realmente a practicar su fe
especialmente en lugares como en nayaf o
como en kerbala pero también se habla de
la Victoria iraní Irán es un país de
mayoría Chita como es la mayoría de edad
con una gran relación con Irak
especialmente en estos lugares de linaje
y ha sido tenido gran influencia
política durante estos 20 años en los
muchos de los grupos políticos que están
en el parlamento y que lideran el país
hoy son prohiranías tienen gran
influencia pero es interesante ver
también Cómo opera la juventud ir aquí
actualmente en esas grandes protestas
que fueron en el país en el 2019 el
eslogan no Estados Unidos no Irán para
ellos esa violencia sectaria que surgió
después de la invasión no existe ellos
no fueron testigos eran muy pequeños y
ellos tratan de desmarcarse tanto de un
país como otro Y tratar de ganar la
independencia de Irak sin embargo esto a
nivel político es muchísimo más
complicado como decía anteriormente la
influencia iraní especialmente en la
política y en la economía y en lugares
como estos es inmensamente grande